Ron is with us in Sacramento hi Ron
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave
my new listener brand-spankin'-new I
have an interesting situation I am going
to receive an inheritance very shortly
at about a million dollars oh my
goodness who was that my father I'm
sorry yeah well yeah thank you but I've
never had money to manage and we have a
mortgage of about three hundred and
fifty thousand dollars three point eight
seventy five percent and which is pretty
good interest rate and I don't know
whether to pay off the mortgage or to
invest like in a money market like like
a municipal bond or something at four
percent I don't know what to do okay let
it a it off or to invest and then it off
more slowly okay well as you said you're
a new listener and you're new to the
concept of managing that much money and
so you're doing something that's very
very wise and that's you're seeking
counsel and trying to learn from people
who have managed money that like that
and you know I'm one but there's others
you could certainly talk to and get into
your corner one of the things we tell
folks when they come into wealth from
whatever method it is when they come
into wealth suddenly is to just go
slowly and learn and you know you just
you just for the first time balanced on
a bicycle you don't have to plan a trip
around the world on bicycles you know
and yeah it you don't have to push it to
the edge you don't suddenly have to be a
genius you don't have to act like you've
got 40 years of experience managing a
million dollars you don't you got 40
minutes maybe as so far experience and
so it's okay to go slow go at the speed
of your understanding not at the speed
of someone else's understanding mine or
somebody trying to sell use
something I'm not trying to sell you
something but even in my situation you
know you don't go at my understanding
you go at the speed of yours because
what will happen is that will rob your
piece and it should rob your piece if
you're doing stupid stuff that you don't
even know what it is because some guy in
a good suit said to do it it sounded
good you see what I'm saying yeah let me
give you an example the example that
you're facing is something like one of
these except you're not a kid one of
these twenty two-year-old kids that gets
drafted in the NFL and gets ten million
dollar check and they don't have any
more chance of holding all that money
that fly the moon unless they go slow
and set themselves up to make a decision
to go at the speed of their
understanding and I don't care if you do
something very very simple with the
money that's better than doing something
stupid with the money agreed yeah so I
want to give you permission and beg you
to do two things one is keep it simple
and twos go slow and have a piece about
what you're doing so the first thing I
would do is park it in CDs and then I
would spend a year making decisions and
learning and collecting data and and
meeting with people and learning and
getting ideas and not trying to find
someone you trust no you're trying to
find someone who will teach you your who
this money was given to not me not some
financial goober somewhere who wants to
make a commission oh I trust John I
don't give a rip
if you trust John or not it's not John's
money it's your money and that's what I
try to tell these young guys and
occasionally I get through to one I got
through to one a while back I I didn't
somebody else got through to him but I
got to meet with him a while back one of
these NFL kids and you know he's played
several years he's played a decade now
and he has 15 million dollars in cash
it's not even invested it's sitting in a
bank account but you know what that's a
better story than the doofuses that lose
it all right right and so I'm happy with
him doing that he said Dave I didn't
know what else to do with it and I knew
he would be there if I did that he
basically put it in a glorified cookie
jar you know what I'm saying
but he had 15 million dollars in a
dadgum cookie jar not bad so I'm proud
of him I think he did great now he needs
to learn though
learn about mutual funds and learn about
real estate and learn about some things
he can put the money in so all of that
to say that's the big part of the
conversation now
what would I do if I woke up in your
shoes knowing what I know I'd write a
check and pay off my house and I would
invest the I mean I would give some of
it I would enjoy some of it I'd take my
wife on a cruise or whatever it is she
wants to do or buy that car you've been
thinking about you can spend a little
bit of it give some of it spend some of
it pay off your house and I would invest
some of it then and I only buy two types
of investments Ron I buy real estate
that I pay cash for and I pay and I buy
mutual funds that have long track
records in good growth stock mutual
funds so I don't know I don't because
and here's the problem the bond market
the interest or the the value of a bond
works inverse opposite of interest rates
in other words as interest rates rise
the value of a bond goes down muni or
corporate bond either one okay and we
are at a you know this from just walking
around since we're at one of the lot in
one of the lowest interest rate
environments we've been in since the
1960s right now
right and so if we're in a low interest
rate environment and bond prices drop
when interest rates go up bonds scare
the crap out of me right now because I
think interest rates are gonna go up at
some point
I don't know when now I don't predicting
10% interest rates but I think you know
if these interest rates go from 3% to 5%
your stinkin muni bonds gonna get get
his throat cut you see what I'm saying
it'll still pay the coupon rate it'll
pay the amount on it but the value the
bond were you to resell it will have
dropped yeah that's what I'm saying so I
it's not as safe as it as they make it
sound especially in this interest rate
environment so again just go slow and
learn and then here's the thing about
paying off your house if you if you pay
off the house and you hate it you can
always go get you another mortgage oh
that's true so you know
there's a little bit of tax advantage
yeah but not really because you're
basically paying out a dollar in
interest and it saves you 35 cents in
taxes yeah so you're trading dollars for
quarters it's not a good trade so I
wouldn't keep it for that reason either
we this is what we had about paying off
the mortgage yep and paying off both of
my kids school
good good that's a good money or not
they're not incurring in it and we don't
really have any other debt and you
already were pretty responsible with
money yeah pretty much
so you're gonna have a bunch of bad
habits that isn't your like you're gonna
go back into debt because you keep
overspending you've not done
overspending your income already no and
the same things true with those kids if
you're gonna pay off those loans their
response has to be that they're going to
be living responsibly going forward
otherwise you're giving a drunk a drink
all right and so you got to kind of work
that through maybe put them through
Financial Peace University or something
but yeah I think that I would do what
I'd write both of those checks I agree
with you assuming the kids are
responsible and assuming you're gonna
keep your habits going forward under
control and I think they're there that's
why I made that suggestion and then I
would sit with a CPA and if you want to
sit with a mutual fund person you can
find one on our website that we
recommend you don't have to but Dave
Ramsey comm just click on ELP on the
right side of the page for investing and
that's a person in order to get my
endorsement run they have to have the
heart of a teacher
I won't endorse someone for investing
unless they have the heart of a teacher
so they'll sit down with you and teach
you they're not gonna be like going oh
I've got a chance to get some money it's
not how they do it so we you know those
guys we stay away from they're kind of
slimy and they're out there in the
business as well so you just got to find
people around you that'll teach you go
slow learn learn learn learn about
mutual funds learn about buying some
real estate for cash that's an
investment real estate if you want to
learn about some of these things just
take you learn about bonds take your
time and learn but you don't have to
learn a lot to figure out
pay off the house pal to get student
loan that's not a bad decision this is
the Dave Ramsey show
you